good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday I hope
everyone's having a great day
I'm not
Jax
well you can't just leave us with that
Claudia what's wrong
you don't even want to know you don't I
can't even say it Theo
well I don't even get me started on Theo
is there something else there is what we
literally had this conversation one week
ago on the toast about partners and
spouses who are just people human beings
who don't respect sleep what Ben woke
you up when he was leaving for his trip
Ben woke me up when he was leaving for
his trip this morning at 4 30.
and I have been up since then why didn't
you fall back asleep I couldn't like
first of all what [__] nerve I just
want to say no now I'm getting I'm
reliving and I'm getting angry what
[__] Nerf whenever I either come home
late and Ben's already asleep or I have
to leave early I literally turn on the
light in the bathroom and I get
annihilated for it like absolutely
[__] annihilated
you know what Ben does this morning what
he's walking around the room with a
flashlight like from his phone
and he wanted to check in on Theo's eyes
so for those who don't know I spent the
night last night at the pet emergency
room Theo is having some focacca
situation he's got like a one-eyed
Mulligan one of them won't open the
doctors don't think it's you know severe
or urge and it looks like a mild
abrasion he's on antibiotics
so drama queen starts going out to do
yeah heart's up for do prayers prayers
every day I was thinking about due all
night brew and I wear on pins and
needles waiting for results Ben's
running around the room with his dumb
ass [__] flashlight
then he comes to the bed with his big
flashlight to like take a look at Theo's
eye like and by big flasher you mean the
light on his phone that's a big
flashlight for sure but it's not like
you know the one it might as well be it
might as well be like a cop's flashlight
okay
and althea's laying with me and Ben's
flashing around his big dumbass light
and flashing it in my goddamn eye
so I'm like oh did you feel like Theo
I'm like oh wow okay a light in my eye
and then he left and oh my God I guess
I'm going back to sleep I know it's 4
30. and that was it for me and I just
I'm I have like anger coursing through
my veins for the [__] lunacy
the lack of consideration and the brain
dead nature of the flashlight usage I'm
like mad I'm [__] mad because I'm
tired I woke up at four [__] 30.
I'm sorry turdy that that's what you're
going through
I'm really pissed you know he thought he
was being considerate though because
he's like skoking around in the dark
with his flashlight why does he need to
check out Theo's eye I'll be up in a few
hours
because he's worried about his boy no
because he's a drama queen and he's like
you know I'm gonna have to take care of
Theo this whole week because Ben is gone
and he just like wants to pretend like
he did something I'm mad and you know
when I spoke to him this morning he was
like I'm sorry I'm like it's okay but
you know what I like now sitting here
like the whole day is ahead of me and I
feel like I've already done a whole day
I'm [__] mad
I'm really I'm like I'm pissed what did
you do from 4 30 on
such a good question
I laid I made a bowl of cereal
I watch Sex in the City
then I watched Casey Jones and the six
then I did my hair
then I gave Theo breakfast then I took
like a pretty decent amount of time
doing my makeup I made the bed oh I
cleaned the house because of course big
fancy Benson for celebrity is going on
his trip he had to turn the house into a
dump so me the maid comes and yeah I
just did the dishes I literally like I
did everything damn
no
um
today is not the day to [__] with me I
guess I shouldn't tell you about
um my experience waking up this morning
because it was get out of here it was
Sublime baby Harry came was plopped on
your chest and give you a big kiss and
said oh Mommy I love you so much
so usually I never make it to my alarm
because Harry wakes us up with his cries
and so I don't ever experience the alarm
I never like have the alarm wake me up I
did get a hatch two days ago and I set
my new alarm on my hatch for a little
earlier than my old alarm on my phone
because I would like to get up before
Harry said I could like be a person and
not just like stumble out of bed and go
into the Caribbean you know like like
frazzled and this morning every once in
a while like he sleeps through the
morning till like hour morning time and
this morning like the hash I got to
experience how the hatch wakes you up
like gradually so I technically like
woke up before my alarm because like the
hatch did that and then literally two
minutes later I had I woke up so I was
like amazing I got to like get a coffee
go in there and just like be human
okay I thought you were like actually
gonna have had like a Sublime like that
just sounds that just sounds like
everything worked out in your face yeah
the timing was right which it rarely
rarely happens like he always wakes up
before I thought you were gonna say oh
Zach let me sleep in he took Harry and
by the time I arose Harry was all
dressed and fed for the day laying in my
bed saying mommy let's go out for scones
today oh I wish but we should go out for
scones today Harry's so gonna grow up to
be British he doesn't even know it yeah
you know when you're like [__] tired
yeah like I'm like I could cry like I'm
really
I'm gonna say this strongly worded
really nasty text to Ben okay fear Ben
and also pray for me who you know I'm
I'm the one who's here to receive all of
this no and I have such a busy [__]
day like what do you have up going on
turdy Lou Who well we have freaking Fred
at five o'clock so hopefully you can nap
and I can't
oh my God I'm like literally so mad I'm
like
what do you have to do today could we
maybe push anything to tomorrow today
well I just have to like take care of
Theo
and
I'm not okay you're crying I've been up
since 4 30.
yeah
I was supposed to start my physical
therapy today the snatcher set me up at
the physical therapist that she worked
with a few years ago that she really
liked his name is Frank
um
because I've been having really bad back
problems so I was gonna do that today
and then I was gonna you know that's
gonna take a while so after the toast
and then
we have breaking bread and then I have
my book club and now I'm just not going
to enjoy any of it I was looking forward
to my PT I was looking forward to my
book club I think you should move PT so
that you can take a nap and that you can
enjoy freaking Fred and book club yeah
I think that's the move I
you know these these men
they become celebrities and they think
you know they forget all about their
wives they treat everyone like [__]
Ben's going to Alabama today
for our meet and greet because he's a
big celebrity for a meet and greet
because he's a big celebrity so if
anybody in Alabama wants to get woke and
defend me wants to go defend me if
anyone in Alabama wants to get woken up
and have a flashlight in their eye go
see Ben no if anybody wants to take up
this cause in Mobile go to Ben's meet
and greet tonight for spritz and he's
gonna go to his meet and greet and it's
going to be like a protest you guys we
should protest outside Yes Should I fly
you should I'll sleep on the plane but
let me ask you something not to
not to victim blame or anything oh no no
no no
why do you think that you couldn't fall
back asleep like for me if like if I
woke up at 4 30 I'm like oh my God three
more hours good night I know normally me
too but like
I I don't know why I didn't fall back
asleep it was also like a gradual wake
up like first he got out of bed and like
you know charged into the bathroom and I
heard that and I said have a safe flight
and then I fell back asleep and then
he's packing with the light running
around the room I'm like oh you're still
here then the lights directly in my eye
when he's flashing Theo so I was like oh
he I know he woke up at 4 30 and by the
time I went to go pee it was five so I
feel like he was walking around for 30
minutes with the light on got it okay
and that's enough time to like really
shake you out and then you're up
and then I'm up so I just feel off I
don't feel right and you know I have my
period
um so that on top of the 4 30 a.m I'm
I'm not one to be [__] with today I
will keep that in mind
can you believe like it's just gonna be
turdy's way today
and that's different than any every
other day it's true no sometimes I put
up a fight you know arguing this point
in that but oh you do actually I'm not
gonna hear a pee pad of me today
I feel like for everyone's safety like
it's best if I'm just I keep to myself
today
you don't think that you need to kind of
let it out
maybe it's best for the ratings if you
don't yeah no like or maybe I mean
whatever attorney wants
do whatever you need to do dirty Lou I
just really hope that people take up for
me at Ben's being great today if you're
listening to this and you live in
Alabama and you're going he is going to
have a miserable time just take up for
me say Not only was Claudia's morning
ruined but my morning was ruined too
because Claudia was a nasty wench on the
toast today yeah because of you yeah
it was you and if you guys want to like
you know make signs and and pick it I
wouldn't be against that either and what
should they the sign say
okay something about how Ben doesn't
support literacy or sleeping
um
or something about you know
no more flashlights I mean maybe that
would be our chant as we stand in a you
know in unity yeah
okay if anybody has any better ideas
drop them in the comments we'd love to
see what what would your picket site and
say in the comments yeah give some ideas
to the Alabama toasters let literate
women sleep yeah
because he knows you know what I feel
like I feel like it was intentional
because tonight's my book club
until you think he was trying to
sabotage you yeah so that I can't enjoy
my book club because I'll be so tired
and he'll be like well maybe you just
shouldn't do it anymore but you know
what I found like sometimes I'm so tired
and I don't want to go to something it's
something that I know I would have
enjoyed but like I just I can't
I don't want to go but like once I'm
there like you really are just there and
you enjoy yourself and you forget how
you felt before a hundred percent
usually that happens but the worst plan
we're about 10 minutes in it hasn't
kicked in yet for you no Ben hasn't
fully thought through his plan
no I will enjoy book club he
underestimated the turdy Lou
100 he always does
always does
importantly more importantly how's Theo
honestly I've never taken a trip to like
the emergency room for pets
um and I didn't even know where my local
one was so this is just a reminder to
everyone to always you know know your
resources I went
um basically after dinner last night
Ben's like what's up with Theo's eye and
one thing about Ben is like he's overly
cautious I'm like it's fine it's fine
it's fine and then I did take a look and
I'm like um I don't know one of them was
like pretty sealed shut and we whisked
whisked him off to the emergency room it
was so sad in the emergency room I mean
I'm not gonna cry start talking I was
crying before bed like it was so sad
they had this candle
and there was a sign above it that said
like if this Candle is lit I'm not I'm
gonna cry
he said if this Candle is lit like
please keep your voices down someone
is saying goodbye
um
it was so depressing I I actually I like
to go in there it gave me perspective
because Theo was fine and they kept
pushing him to the back of the line
because every time another because it
wasn't that urgent no so every time
another dog came in I like really
realized how like literally Theo is okay
my other dog it was it was so sad and
like this girl was there she was by
herself she was like making the
emergency room was like actually really
emotional
she was like by herself which I just
feel like is so scary she was like young
and her dog like was like this
oh my God it was so scary and that's
just when the doctor was finally getting
to Theo and the girl walked in the
doctor was like you're gonna need to
hold on a minute and I was like yeah of
course go
um
and then when the doctor came back I was
like how is that little bulldog and she
was like it doesn't look good what
happened to him
um
I don't know like I did over here I was
being really nosy
um like the bulldog has like discs in
his back you know French Bulldogs have
really bad back problems
I remember Brian used to have a French
Bulldog and
he actually had to start living with
Brian's friend in Florida because he
can't walk upstairs and the guy had like
a house with no stairs
um
so we had discs in his back and
basically I heard her say like I think
she said I know I sound crazy I think
she said fentanyl patch
like the dog had like this patch on his
back because he was in so much pain and
it just ran out and he started to I
guess the pain all came back and the dog
was like
got it and even when they took him back
into the like
room I still heard the panting it was
really sad oh wow I know I hope to never
take another trip back there was so
depressing
so our do is doing well better on the
mend he's not the thing is and why it
was never really truly worried it's like
his spirits were High the whole time if
Theo is ever lethargic then I'm
concerned but he was like wagging his
tail wanting to play with the other dogs
but you know one of his eyes was just
not working yeah
they took a look they said he has a mild
abrasion on one of his eyes it shouldn't
be a big deal an antibiotic drop slash
like ointment thing will should clear it
up in a week so we started that last
night I did it this morning it's hard to
get him to get you know those drops in
his eyes sure he's a fighter and he
doesn't need to wear an eye patch I feel
like maybe he should he's wearing a cone
and I he wouldn't keep an eye patch on
but what is a cone gonna do for him like
he can't scratch his own eyes oh he
can't scratch yeah which could be the
reason how he got the abrasion in the
first place they love that could make it
yeah or it could just make it worse
okay well pair us up it was a rough
night thinking of the French Bulldog as
well I know I broke up this morning with
a heavy heart like feeling for the
French Bulldog I feel hopefully he gets
another patch and finds relief but it's
not a long-term solution
oh did we have an age on the French
Bulldog no I I couldn't hear I was like
being a busy body and a half I just
wanted to see like when other people
like had going on yeah but also you see
the dog come in and then naturally you
want to know what what's going on like
you you care oh yeah like this guy
brought his cat in I mean I literally
knew everything that was going on and
the cat was making like such sad sounds
in the carrier and the guy was
explaining how
the cat got caught in his box spring
and I don't know he went straight to the
back was this like a Group Forum like
was it just like a circle where like
every question it's a good question it's
like hey are there not cordoned off
rooms where there is examinations so
actually the reason why I went to this
place is because it's one of the few in
the city that lets you stay with your
dog the entire time
oh actually the non-threatening slash
urgent like Theo's appointment so
there's a reception with like the desk
and chairs and stuff and in that room
there's an examination table
Theo actually had his appointment in
reception because they don't let you
separate from your dog okay some of the
more heavy serious cases went to the
back room okay but actually that's why I
was in reception the entire time yeah
you're right so you see everyone splayed
out it's kind of like
it was like kind of like a free-for-all
it's like group therapy it was kind of
chaotic and you know what the longer I
sat there the less concerned I got
because I saw people with like real
problems yeah perspective perspective
but it was a but still it was scary for
do we don't minimize what do has gone
through no we don't and you're right I
think I should move my physical therapy
today like I think I need to be with two
yeah and also like why does Frank need
this yeah no this is not the energy
Frank doesn't want to meet this turdy
Lou no murder said Frank was like such a
great guy he deserves better and he did
great work but like I was really looking
forward to getting you know someone to
look at my back today you know yeah your
back will have to wait the OSI takes
priority yeah that's just free
greater than back
thanks for hearing me out you know as
you feel better then like I did I feel
like a lot of my anger has just paid it
like I still want to kill Ben but I'm
not going to take it out on the toast
persevered we made it through it to the
other side
you come in it's kind of like Urgent
Care like you come in with your distress
whatever it is all of you listening and
we're gonna make it through together
we're gonna put you on the examination
table in reception
and we're gonna find out what's wrong
and we're just gonna let you splayed out
for everyone but we're gonna fix it
yeah
so I just want to let everyone know like
whatever attitude you get for me today
like that every day oh my God it's like
every day you have your excuse lined up
for like yeah Jackie it's a [__]
excuse [__] it's called context sorry
yeah you have your explainers
it's just important that everybody knows
like I'm a human you're a human we are
going through things and personally I'm
dealing with a rough 12 hours yeah yeah
and like that's what the show is about
sharing our experiences and
for good and bad
thank you it's not always going to be
you know coming back from Portugal but
it's not always going to be diamonds and
Rose but it should be it should be but
it's not
it's not she was she was so right about
that Lisa
yeah
it's pretty obvious but yeah
um facts that's fair
I think we should get into the stories
because weirdly it's popping off on a
Tuesday Jackie had six she had to
whittle it down I had like no I had like
eight but then Claudia really want to
talk about one story so I had to yes I
had to whittle down to four
I'm so excited to read someone to filth
today especially given my mood oh and
hopefully tomorrow's a slow day so then
some of my others that weren't even
really that b list could make it to the
story it's like I'm feeling good I've
got stories for days oh I'm sorry I
didn't notice because it was like in my
own like situation uh you're looking so
Pregnant yeah well I am pretty pregnant
and then also you show sooner faster
bigger like when you're not in your
first pregnancy do you know that is that
true no yes very true like it's what
they say and it also is what I do belly
like let me see
yeah I actually I was about to post a
video to my Instagram because I like I
like when I do like a mirror picture and
then like I turn to the side and it's
like yeah Ellie boom
um yeah so because yesterday on the show
like I love my sweatsuit but like it
looks like absolute [__] garbage in
the reels and so I was like maybe it was
just too big so now I'm trying the
opposite of wearing something like
svelte to see if I look smaller because
I looked like a big fat [__] listen
we said this was not the year of
negative self-talk and we're certainly
not calling ourselves big fat [__] when
we're pregnant the thing is I'm not the
thing is I actually I'm not like blaming
myself for that like I think it was the
sweatsuit and the chair and the camera
angle like they were not a mix it's
really not me because I don't know if I
told you guys this Turtle knows but like
I went to the doctor for my like you go
once a month and in the last month of
pregnancy I only gained one pound and do
you think that one pound like was the
baby
no because the the baby's not even a
pound yet oh but it's just like it's so
easy to just put on weight when you're
pregnant because it's like [__] right
right but you also like need to put on
weight that's outside of the baby like
the placenta ways and this and that and
also like you got to live your life but
one pound in a month like I'm like
healthy Queen okay so so I'm really not
even feeling like
super big outside of pregnancy but like
the the sweatsuit just like wasn't
helping me yesterday so I thought I
would try something different like uh
skin tight you look bad how many months
are you I can ever keep up I'm in my
fourth month
fourth month okay yeah
people keep asking me like what does
Jackie do I don't know
it's probably for the best like I don't
need everyone to know my business no
it's so true that's like a kind of a
kind of a blessing of having like a
sister who has a big mouth but it's also
forgetful yeah yeah yeah
so true so true well you look great
thank you so much hopefully I'll see
when we rap if this was the right mover
if I should just go back to wearing
leggings in the bar sweatshirt like if
it ain't broke don't fix it that's me
today leggings and a sweatshirt if it
ain't broke
don't [__] fix it [__] yeah but
sometimes like those reels like I like
how I look on the YouTube and then in
the reals I'm like who is that
not not my plate this is not my plate
it's not I know you don't feel that way
because you're just having the opposite
life experience right now where every
day you're just like smaller than you
even thought uh but you know that we
have something for everyone here yeah
yeah and we always will
hopefully
so now without further Ado
here are the past five stories that you
need to know
today's episode is brought to you by the
black talks not to get all parental but
it's time we have the talk you know the
one about that three-letter word that
ends in X we're talking about attacks
and when you need a tux the best place
to go to is the black tux the blacktox
makes it super easy to get an on Trend
top quality guaranteed to fit tux
without ever leaving your house here's
how it works take the black tux fit quiz
pick the style you want to rock and boom
your tuxes delivered to your door 10
days before the day you need it it's
plenty of time to try it on and make
sure it wears you well and hey if it's
not quite right say hello to the black
tux fit guarantee order a better size
within a day or two of receiving the
less than great fitting one and they'll
send another one right away at no extra
cost and if you prefer in-store
experience the black tux has showrooms
across the country they're expert fit
Specialists will help you find the
perfect style tux or suit and make sure
it fits just right
um Ben got a text from the blacktalks he
enjoyed the process a lot mostly because
I think he just in general like didn't
like the traditional way of going again
a tux and it's just like a lot of work
and having it come to the house and
doing it all online was really great and
he got a great tux renter Buys so he
doesn't deserve it no he deserves
nothing in my opinion the black tux is
the best place to go to when you need a
tuxedo for a wedding or a special night
right now when you get to
theblacktucks.com toast and use code
toast you'll save 20 off your order
that's
t-h-e-b-l-a-c-k-t-u-x.com slash toast
code toast to save twenty dollars
theblattux.com toast code toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
bowling Branch wake up feeling rested
and refreshed very similar to how I'm
feeling today with the softest most
luxurious sheets from Bolin Branch the
bet the betting experts they make the
highest quality sheets with Incredible
craftsmanship you guys know the bowling
Branch Jackie and I are huge fans of
everything that they make my entire set
of sheets are from Bowling Branch at my
house at my room in Jackie's house my
throw blanket I have a bunch of
different accessories it's really a
great brand
so what we both have is the signature
hemmed collection from Bowling Branch
it's their best seller uses the highest
quality 100 organic cotton threads on
Earth each sheet set is slow made for a
superior softness and a better night's
sleep they feel buttery to the hot to
the touch they are super breathable and
they're perfect for both cooler and
warmer weather they're loved by millions
of sleepers they're so luxurious and
they have over 10 000 rave reviews they
come in 10 different colors and sizes
from Twin up to California King what's
great about bowling branch is that their
products are made without toxins they're
made without synthetic pesticides
formaldehyde other harsh chemicals and
they fit the deepest of mattresses and
they are labeled with a top and bottom
tag so when you're making making your
bed it is that much easier with bowl and
Branch if you're not sure you can check
it out and you'll get a 30 night
risk-free guarantee with free shipping
and Returns on all U.S orders so sleep
better at night with bowling Branch
sheets get 15 off your first order when
you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com that's bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com promo code toast exclusion
Supply Seaside for details
bowlingbranch.com promo code toast
they're the best sheets to sleep on when
someone will let you sleep
they're the best sheets to sleep on
asterisk footnote when somebody will let
you sleep
first story
Amanda is actually I think it's Kismet
how our sponsors today were literally
for Ben and forbid
yeah and what does that say
don't you find it weird how there's only
one letter difference between Ben and
bed
I do find that strange and it's like
just one thing when awry
actually really two things
Ben and bed yeah yeah yeah but it's like
you can't connect maybe because that
letter changed yeah I just I find it
interesting that the
that it that it's in it's in the
it's in the ads you know like the even
the ads know yes but I think we'll be
able to make any AD applicable to this
situation yeah because like when when
you're so mad like it takes over your
whole being every your whole vision is
clouded you see everything through the
lens of oh my God it's like if we have
State Farm it's like you need insurance
because you're gonna kill your husband
like no cause I'm gonna burn down this
house yeah well actually I don't think
insurance covers arson if it's like your
house or murder but yeah um like what
else do we have today do you know
I do well we actually I know you're
excited because you've been dying to
talk about fastgardingtrees.com because
you got a new tree in your backyard I
did and you know what Ben is gonna need
some of my fresh growing trees when he's
out on the streets and needs yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and we also have Skylight
frames which I will be changing the
photo on my
on my table from a photo of me and Ben
to a photo of me and Theo yeah
deserves everybody you're right they're
all applicable
I am excited to talk about fast growing
trees though Jackie's been like non-stop
talking about this nutrient or backyard
that I got from fast growing trees it's
an orange tree and then it I it inspired
me like find a place for it and the
place that I found for it is actually
the perfect place to start a little bit
it's not the time no but okay but can I
talk about that I'm going to start a
garden
yeah but you why don't you save it for
when we talk about fresh scoring trees
okay by the way teaser spoiler alert
pretend you didn't hear that yeah our
first story
Amanda Bynes has been placed on
psychiatric hold after roaming the
streets of Los Angeles naked
Amanda Bynes has been placed on a
psychiatric hold TMZ has learned after
she was found roaming the streets naked
and alone and eyewitness told TMZ Amanda
was seen walking near downtown LA early
Sunday morning without any clothes we're
told Amanda waved a car down telling the
driver she was coming down from a
psychotic episode Amanda herself then
called 9-1-1 the law enforcement sources
say Amanda was taken to a nearby police
station where a mental health Team
determined she needed to be placed on a
5150 psych hold fortunately our sources
say it doesn't appear Amanda was hurt at
all during the ordeal though things
could have been much worse given the
area where she was found
a source close to Amanda tells TMZ she's
currently hospitalized and will likely
continue to receive care for several
days typically a psychiatric hold only
lasts 72 hours but it can be extended
um also her parents have said that they
are not looking into doing another
conservatorship after this
incident
um well I have to say like to have the
wherewithal to like under like as you're
coming down to ask for help and call
9-1-1 like is something it's like a
that's a huge deal
um I just whenever I talk about Amanda
Minds like I get really sad yeah
I feel like
something happened to her
um
and I don't think we'll really ever know
what it is but she's such a a talent and
I think so many people like us included
feel like they grew up with her and
every time we report on like a you know
when she takes a step back in her in her
journey it makes me really sad it does
make me really sad and I also like I
have to commend the driver that would
pull over for a naked woman flagging the
car down I feel like most people
wouldn't like it surprises me that
someone stopped for her and helped her
because like if you see like a person
walking around naked down you would say
oh you're like you know
trying to take it out of the way yeah so
I'm glad he's everyone recognized her
maybe but she's kind of unrecognizable
these days like she looks just different
from how we remember her like she has
black hair
um
so I'm glad that she was able to get
help from a Good Samaritan before like
this article says like things could have
gotten so much worse considering the
area that she was in yeah like highly
trafficked she's naked yeah and
vulnerable it's just really scary no I
know and I'm I'm just curious like who
who does she have around her I know she
she kind of has her parents right I
think she's a boyfriend Paul
yeah and I've broken up I think she has
her parents too
um
the thing is the conservatorships have
gotten such a bad rap rap that it's like
you never want to be someone to advocate
for conservatorship I also don't know
her story I also don't know really
anything about conservatorships only
like Britney and how horrible that was
I'm sure they are intended to do good
yeah and I don't know that this
situation means that she should be under
conservatorship I don't know what any of
it means um but they clearly have a lot
on their hands yeah I think for the most
part conservatorships are meant to be
you know positive and protect the person
for a temporary amount of time
um obviously we all have like a bad
connotation now because of Brittany but
I think for the most part like they do a
lot of good like Tom Girardi's in a
conservatorship right now yeah but he's
another just negative example
well of a of a of a situation and you
could say like there is the argument
that he's actually not as unwell as he
pretends to be yeah in order to not so
another
I'm sure there are good examples of yeah
yeah
um I just feel sad for Amanda binds like
I I feel like whenever we talk about her
and she and she makes strides we're
always saying like we want her back in
the game doing movies but I think you
know that's pretty much out of the realm
of possibility yeah she had been work
she'd been going to college for fashion
design and it seemed like she was making
progress and doing well in that Arena I
don't think we'll ever
have her acting doing comedy again I
don't think that maybe she should
because like you said clearly something
happened
I imagine it was in the Hollywood toxic
sphere of course and it's best to stay
out of there yeah
I just I really wish her well me too
me too
I hope she gets the help that she needs
are you ready for our next story yes
which is some incredibly happy
heartwarming news that I think turdy Lou
needs on this Tuesday yeah Luke Combs
and his wife Nicole are expecting their
second baby they are joining the two
under two Club so country singer on our
fave Luke Combs and his wife Nicole
Hawking Combs are expecting their second
child they announced last night with the
cutest announcement ever so it was a
collage of photos of them and their baby
texts and overlaid was one of Luke's new
songs and tex was wearing a shirt that
said big brother right and the song is
called take you with me and the lyrics
that we got were just all about how he
wants to take his son like everywhere
with him and even if he like can't
understand it yet like what he's doing
and where he's going like he just wants
him to be everywhere with him I
literally like facts straight facts so I
love the song I love the announcement
I'm so happy for them that they're
having another one I know that was a
surprise how old is Texas he's not one
yet I think he was born in May I think
April let's get some candles burning
some records turn in all the lights down
low taking nice and slow the way he must
have played that song and said Nico get
over here yeah first comes the kind of
love we make then comes take you with me
well actually if we're gonna do that we
it goes all the way back
beautiful crazy Beauty no no no no he
said which songs are connected Forever
After All Better Together you're first
in my last name oh yeah no no but we're
just talking about the love making yeah
but you gotta get married first comes
love
then comes Forever After all then Better
Together
Better Together how the love we make
kind of love we make then comes take you
with me in the baby carriage oh so cute
you know and
I think we said this last time when they
were naming their first son how like
there's a lot of pressure on them to
kind of like be and come up with the
most like original Contra name and they
really killed it with text so hard to do
it again no you guys naming the second
is even harder than aiming a first
because for your first you really have
names that you've always loved and so
for the second if you don't have more
names that you loved or like you ran out
like for the second it's like names that
you've seen all throughout your life
that you never once thought like I would
like to name my child this and now all
of a sudden you have to look at that
name and be like that's my child you
have to take another look and say there
might be something there that wasn't
there before it's so true Claudia sent
me this account last night oh I was just
gonna bring that up no you didn't send
you sent me something else but oh I saw
Megan McCain posted an image from this
account called Nameberry where she gives
like a category and then like really
specific name options or like if you
like this name but it's become really
popular try this name yeah that's the
same thing as what I sent you yes yes uh
but it was more it was in graphics like
cambos much more digestible no I love
this girl on Tick Tock I just randomly I
don't know why I got targeted one of her
videos but she's a baby name consultant
um and she seemed really smart like she
had a lot of knowledge of like Bible and
history and like phonetics and
linguistic and so she's doing a series
it's called not this but that like do
you love a name but you can't use it
because your friend had it or your
cousin
um
comment a name and she does a series
where like once a week or maybe a couple
times a week she'll choose someone was
like I wanted to name my daughter
Madison but you know my best friend did
that what can I do instead and she'll
come up with a name and I can't really
explain like here this morning she did
for somebody you can't use the word the
name Sloan s-l-o-a-n
try Reese and like I can't explain why
it's the same Vibe it's the same Vibe
yeah
like okay you want to use um
wait like she actually I I can't I don't
know what's like the um
the science behind why it makes sense
okay here
because I thought this wasn't was really
good
she said if you can't do
wrong one just give me one second and
then you know what I'll show you some of
these name Berry ones it's such a cute
idea for content by the way like I feel
like moms like it is I went so deep I
thought this was so good because I've
always I really like the name Piper but
let's say you can't use the name Piper
go for Daphne like that makes sense yeah
yeah wait but her name is her Tick Tock
name is naming Bebe if anyone cares
naming Bebe okay
let me find
just some of these are so hard Claudia
it's so hard do you have like names that
you're ready to name
um
like kind of
um but like no
you know the the good thing about you
know waiting a little longer than your
siblings to have children is like you
know you get to live but the bad thing
is all like the good family names get
taken mm-hmm
like Harold like Michael Michaela you
know
that that part definitely sucks so if
anything is like getting me to start
wanting to have kids it's like to snatch
one of the remaining names
yeah before like the two older siblings
have it all and Margo and I are out here
with like Sloan
David and Daphne yeah
what were you looking for I was looking
for the list of names that it was like
if you like this it was or it was like
themes if you want like floral names it
was like really pretty floor names that
aren't just like the obvious ones oh and
that was the other thing that I like
that that Tick Tock account does she
takes into consideration names that have
currently cracked like the top 20. yeah
and she won't recommend them yeah no but
it will be like if you liked this try
this yes like because there are names
right now that are so popular I was
looking at like most popular boy names
by state and it's like
you just can't the most popular name is
it is number one but it's also like
literally number one in every state for
girls is Olivia oh I'm so jealous I know
it's a gorgeous name it's a gorgeous
name do you like your name I do but I
also like it because I'm Jackie O
you've did you feel like a Jackie
well no because Jackie I like the name
Jackie but I feel like special because
I'm Jackie out if I didn't have Jackie
okay but I'm not saying Jackie oh I'm
saying Jackie
like to me you are such a Jackie like
Jackie is you and you are Jackie yeah
and I think it's very like it emblematic
of you thanks
but there's also like so many jockeys
weirdly I've like not been super really
close with Jackie throughout my life but
like
there's just like Jackie's out there
there are Jackies out there but they're
not on every corner they're not on every
corner and they're certainly not a lot
of turdy lose on every corner well let
me tell you how like I've literally
never met another human being named
Claudia maybe every now and then
there'll be like a Claudia in the book
but she's never the main characters
she's always like the irrelevant ugly on
the side and I like low-key I'm not
crazy about my name you're wrong for
that really yeah it's so beautiful I
feel like out of all the sisters we all
have really beautiful names and also you
must remember that my real name is
Jacqueline so more a little more
beautiful than Jackie for sure but like
that's literally not your name no but
it's like when you when you put it
with the rest of like our names it just
like it presents nicer we all have
really pretty names but mine is probably
the most common even though it's not
even like
Rachel well um I don't know you just
said Olivia's top ten
yeah now but Olivia is a million years
old
when she was named it it wasn't common
yeah yeah not us like finding a way to
make Nico homes is um announcement about
us
yeah
do you have any predictions I love your
name I love maybe my sister's names
another like State Vibe you know because
texts yeah like maybe not a state but
like I said Austin yeah Phoenix I'm
assuming it's a boy did she say she is a
boy oh cute cute Phoenix Baron room
right like something in terms of like
land you know yeah
like there's some Montana names like
that yeah they'll come up with something
good you know they love a little
um
I can't speak today I'm sorry
so you're just going to leave the
sentence redneck imagery that's what
Luke Combs said to us when we
interviewed him on the red carpet that
his music is Redneck imagery it is and
speaking of his music the song take me
with you comes out on Friday so prepare
for Tears on Friday I'm just I need to
prepare like it's enough I need this
album five leaf clover so good Joe so
good love you anyways so good like I'm
ready for the album sir I'm ready for
the album but really my music cup has
run us over right now like I have so
many albums that I'm listening to and
sometimes there's such a dearth that I
just kind of like wanna wait when does
the album come out
it's amazing question I want to say the
end of the month
I'm really not ready
and I'm still listening to growing up
all the time
like that's in my rotation growing up
Amelia new Morgan Wallen rolling up the
welcome mat like it's too much pink yeah
it's too much
it's like then there were so many times
when I've got nothing no because the
summer is coming up like low-key it's
sneaking up on us and we need songs for
the summer so that's what's coming out
in the next couple of weeks
okay turdy Lou Who
I won't argue with you
are you ready for our next story that
was a turdy Lou original yes and
everyone should really pray for this
woman because of the form that turdy Lou
is in yeah plus you know even on a
Kinder day she's not taken kindly to
this story yeah read it Anna Marie
tendler who
is also very well known as John
mulaney's ex-wife
the woman John Mulaney left Olivia Munn
for so we give her I give her a little
bit of Grace because she's been through
a lot she reacts to backlash after
accusing Taylor Swift of copying her art
so Anna Marie tender claimed she was
only kidding when she accused Taylor
Swift of copying her art on the singer's
era's tour the artist said in a tick
tock video she said that the stage set
up during Swift's song tolerated looked
quote strikingly like one of her
photographs in tone and in Aesthetics in
the now deleted upload she showed the
decorations which featured a dining
table and candles followed by her own
2021 portrait for comparison she wrote
what the [__] then she asked her
followers for help adding quote it
doesn't totally feel like parallel
thinking to me I'm a small artist an
independent artist who's trying to make
money and live off of my artwork after
trolls criticized the allegation she
called the footage a joke or satire in a
comment she said when I realized it
wasn't Landing as a joke I deleted it
didn't mean any offense however tiktok
users express feelings about her
explanation and the it was a joke
defense when the thing he went seriously
turned out to be horribly out of touch
yeah another she can't seriously be
accusing of Taylor Swift of stealing her
idea of setting a table but sure
piggyback off another artist to get your
name out there yeah Chandler's Defenders
meanwhile wrote that her video was
obviously a joke calling haters simply
unable to read her tone if it was a joke
like this
sense of humor but honestly reading back
what she said like and reading it
knowing that it was a joke if it wasn't
really a joke and she meant it as a joke
it's honestly like kind of funny I know
but like I kind of wish
you like
okay so let's just start at the
beginning because I saw this tick tock
and I'm like oh my God such a stretch
first of all like a dining room table is
not an original idea that you can of
course own
um and so on stage Taylor is like
setting a dining room table and it's
meant to convey you know this
relationship that's really one-sided and
I guess Anna Marie tender is like a
photographer and she has like a photo of
herself that she sells for like six
grand of her sitting at a dining room
table with like nobody on the other end
you know
um
so not only is that like not an original
idea that you can like have as your own
to think that but then to say it out
loud is so embarrassing and I'm telling
you I watched the video like Jackie
there's no semblance of a joke like it's
not a joke and I think the absolute
loseriest response to something that you
can do is be like I was kidding like you
were it you thought you were ripped off
so stand by it because to make an
accusation like that against Taylor like
you know everyone's gonna come for you
even if you have even if your accusation
had Merit you know her fans are going to
come for you so you need to be prepared
also if she was joking she's making fun
of these small artists who do always say
like so and so so my idea I'm an
independent artist who's trying to make
money and live off my artwork and so
like I think that that's kind of funny
but I'm not like in like the art world
and no that's worse yeah it is kind of
worse because like she is an artist and
I feel like she is someone who would
like take some of that stuff seriously
we just seen like so many versions of it
at this point like I feel like the first
few times that we saw it it was really
clear like there was copying happening
but now people will do it about anything
so she might be making fun of that Trend
but I just
it's a really niche
joke
it's a bad joke and she's an artist not
a comedian
um so like it's important to keep that
in mind and like I just if we're taking
the video on face value her being like
I'm trying to make a living like she
literally sells photos of herself for
like five to ten Grand and her
ex-husband is John Mulaney like she's
completely fine
hence why it might have been a joke
right
but it wasn't funny like yikes yeah yeah
jokes should be funny but like I don't
know maybe she should be funny oh really
I didn't see the video but now I'm sure
if I watched it now and like knew it was
a joke I would find it funny because
that is like something that people do
all the time like oh I did this and this
person did that they copied me when it
really is parallel thinking like two
people can have the idea to sit at a
dining table alone
okay now you're kind of like making me
think like maybe it was a joke like but
like it wasn't Jackie she was like
visibly shaken in the video like but you
don't think she was putting on like one
of these people who's like
oh I don't know ish I mean if okay here
wait I can watch it for myself yeah
watch it
oh here I am put your speaker near your
mic so people over here hold on I'm
watching a video of me right now how did
that happen why I don't know I'm I keep
trying to click this link from oops
deleted videos
Tick Tock video
okay
design Taylor's tour
uh this tolerated setup looks strikingly
like one of my photographs in in tone
and in Aesthetics
um it doesn't totally feel like parallel
thinking to me
I'm a small artist
uh independent artist
who's trying to make money and live off
of my artwork
uh I don't know what to do about this
and maybe somebody can
okay now hearing it again like through
the lens of like perhaps it being a joke
like it is kind of funny and I think it
is a joke but she's [__] roasting
these small creators who like claim that
everyone who does something similar to
them is stealing their art no and by the
way there is legitimate thievery that
goes on like for sure but people get so
carried away because like people those
types of videos like get a lot of
Engagement and it's like great exposure
for like an artist or whatever
um but they're out of hand like when I
see people being like I went for a walk
and then Ariana Grande went for a walk
it's like calm down like every they take
it too far so like and I guess that's
kind of the the the message she's kind
of sending with her it's extremely like
Niche and convoluted and hard to
understand and I feel if I knew Anna
Marie tendler's personality like if I
follow her for years I would be able to
tell you whether or not this was a joke
but this is like the first time I've
ever seen her speak so I don't know does
she actually talk like that when she's
being serious or is she like being like
that's mine is she right here's the
question is she a weenie or is she not
because I was giving weenie energy and
is that how she is yeah I I'm inclined
to give her the benefit of the doubt
and if so it's a funny joke and like
everyone
I feel it's bad that it did she must
have a pet I feel bad it didn't go the
way that she had wanted
I feel bad as well yikes yeah yikes
yeah
it's not it's not great no it's not but
I'm gonna I'm gonna give her the benefit
of the doubt because I think she could
use the grace in the situation and I
know we teased this earlier but we kind
of have some breaking news from
fastgrowingtrees.com breathe some life
into your own backyard with
fastgrowingtrees.com this spring from
shade to fresh fruit to privacy and
natural beauty let fastgrowingtrees.com
help you plan your dream garden with
their expert advice and fast reliable
shipping so fastgoingtrees.com
plant experts curate thousands of easy
to grow plant shrub and tree varieties
for your unique climate Meyer lemons to
Evergreens and everything in between
tell me about your experience checks had
you land on an orange tray so my
experience shopping at
fastgrowingtrees.com was amazing because
obviously I'm not a tree expert and I
know that there are some trees that grow
really well in Florida and you know
there's others that are for you know
different different climates like
obviously I'm not getting a pine tree
but with fast-foring trees like you put
in where you live and they tell you what
zone you're in and then you can search
for trees that are compatible with your
zone so I literally could look at every
single tree then I almost got
um some sort of lemon tree but then I
read it wasn't really safe for pets I
was like no can do they really like make
it so easy for someone who's obviously
not a tree connoisseur to find the right
tree for them I did want some citrus
trees in my yard at some point so I got
an orange tree I planted it and I had to
find the right area for it where it
would get sun where I could water it
um and I found an area that I'm actually
going to turn into a little garden when
I oh no longer pregnant because you
cannot Garden when you're pregnant
but the tree is just planting the tree
and letting it Blossom and also I love
the orange tree because it's a pretty
low lift eventually it'll yield fruit
and I'm gonna have a lot of oranges and
I'm not gonna share any of them with Ben
good
join Over 1.5 million happy fast growing
trees customers go to
fastgrowingtrees.com toast now to get 15
off your entire order just like Jax get
15 off your order at
fastgrowingtrees.com toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
Skylight frames so you know what I
actually had like a whole script planned
for this read about how you know Ben's
birthday is coming up and I've been just
like really loving Ben but I'm Gonna
Change let's do like a narrative change
last night really put into perspective
how important Theo is for me
and that's why I got a skylight frame
and filled it with pictures of Theo
pictures of me and Theo picture of Theos
and Bruno Theo and Jackie
you know day-to-day life trips work gets
in the way
and it's easy to forget you know about
our loved ones but thanks to Skylight
frame they're on top of it so when you
miss your loved ones and you're not
together or they miss you here's a gift
that brings you all together no matter
how far apart you live the Skylight
frame will bring you close together the
Skylight frame is a touch screen photo
frame that your whole family can email
photos to and appear in seconds Theo's
always on his phone I'm like Theo get
off your phone no phones at the dinner
table he's like Mom I'm sending this
cute pic of me to the Skylight frame and
I said Theo it's okay so you can
basically email your photos to the frame
they'll appear in seconds you'll get to
share your favorite moments with the
people that matter most to you so it's a
great gift for parents for someone with
a birthday coming up someone who just
had a baby new grandparents or even just
for yourself it's a real photo frame
that adds a beautiful touch to your home
it holds thousands of photos that
continuously rotate throughout the day
and bring joy the Skylight frame has a
gorgeous touchscreen and it comes in two
sizes the original 10 inch and now a new
15 inch Gallery frame they have 100
satisfaction guaranteed so if you don't
love your Skylight they'll give you a
full refund time goes fast but staying
in touch with those we love is more
important than ever and now this guy
light frame makes it easy and fun as a
special offer for our listeners get 15
off your purchase of a skylight frame
when you go to skylightframe.com toast
to get that 15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame go to skylightframe.com
toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash
toast it's seriously the perfect gift
you give it to someone and then like
send them the cutest picture that you
took of like your kid that day and they
like it's their first time seeing it on
a frame in their house like that's so
sweet I just sit by my frame and like
see what everyone's gonna send to it you
know I'm I'm kind of like you know uh
Regina George I don't send them I just
get them
that's so true so true our next story
Shaquille O'Neal is reassuring fans that
there's no need to worry after having
some hip surgery he said just got some
BBL work Shaq is in good spirits after
having hip surgery the retired NBA star
told fans he was doing just fine a day
after he posted a photo to his social
media account showing him in a hospital
bed with an IV attached to him so I
think at first people were really
concerned like Shaq what's going on here
in the hospital so he said to all the
people who are worried and concerned
first off let me say thank you and
lastly no need to worry just had to get
some BBL work AKA hip replacement thanks
and love you all but no need to worry
and yes I'm fine
you know what I feel like I learned this
from Emily Simpson from The Real
Housewives of Orange County Kris Jenner
and my friend's mom who recently just
got one like a hip replacement is
literally like
the best thing that can ever happen to
like someone of a certain age like they
say it gives you a totally new life like
remember when Emily Simpson from Orange
County house I was like out here doing
cartwheels with her new hip yeah and she
was like I never would have been able to
do this and Kris Jenner too and it's
like such a low lift 30-minute surgery
and it like really changes your life
yeah well Shaq had had a goal to lose 60
pounds by his 51st birthday and he just
turned 51 he had lost 40 pounds so far
so he got the hip replacement surgery to
help him not to help him lose the next
20 but like that's going to give him you
know even more of the flexibility to
lose the next 20 and then he said he's
going to be doing underwear commercials
with his kids
I don't even know how like an
anesthesiologist would like do the math
to get checked down like he's so big and
I feel like they have to get like a
special table he can't fit on like a
regular operating room table right it
looks like a regular table there's no
way and you know that they put like an
artificial hip in that's what it is
you're kind of like a bionic man or
woman yeah yeah he definitely had to get
special Parts made like he's too big
yeah no he definitely needed a bigger
hip than yeah Christian I would need
yeah
that's interesting
I just often think about all the
accommodations that probably need to be
made for Shaq like of course the first
thing that comes to mind is like travel
but he probably travels private most of
the time anyway so that doesn't seem
like a big deal but just like everyday
life things and thank God Shaq became
rich and famous because like if it
wasn't like Shaq could not fit in like
regular first class no or like a regular
car a sedan right or an Uber or a taxi
or the subway even yeah
thank God Jack is Rich like yeah I
wonder if he thinks about that like
expresses gratitude of course for all
the things he have but how difficult his
life would be if not yeah and how old is
her custom
it's tall but it's also wide and like
girth yeah he's also um everything he
wears is custom clothing because he
can't shop I don't even think he could
shop at the Big and Tall store but like
what about the people who are Shaq's
eyes who aren't rich and famous I don't
think seriously there are a lot of
people I would imagine if you're that
tall like you're automatically a good
basketball player because you could just
like stand at the hoop and just like
touch them all the men right so like was
Shaq even a good player
or did he just stand at the hoop and
make sure every ball went in right and
just oversee what was going on below
because he could see the whole thing
yeah
it's it's a question worth asking yeah
you should ask Ben at a later date not
not today I'm so done with him yeah
don't make him feel like big and smart
today I feel like actually speaking like
Shaq is one of Ben's Idols like Ben
loves Shaq he seems like an awesome guy
based on my limited knowledge of the
sports world like he's obviously a great
athlete he's a father of many he's a now
a PR a commentator he's a DJ he's a
businessman like he's funny too with his
BBL joke like he seems like an
all-around great guy who's not affected
by the fame and the riches yeah and I
feel like we spoke about this once
because like a couple of months ago
maybe actually like a year ago there was
a story about how Shaq paid for
everyone's checks at a restaurant in the
city remember
oh she's about to sneeze but but she
remembers
um I do remember and we were talking
about how like he was on a date with a
girl like what must it be like to be
intimate with Shaq like you know this
morning I was about to say last night
but it was this morning I watched that
episode of Sex in the City where
Samantha runs into that guy on the
street and
he says to her like listen I've had a
lot of trouble with the ladies because
I'm extremely well endowed and she's
like oh trust me it's nothing I can't
handle and she actually ends up not
being able to handle it and they just
have to be friends I feel like the chuck
yeah maybe that's his struggle
right
maybe that's the thing that well I mean
he had a number of children so somebody
did it somebody handled it yeah and then
gave birth to you know children related
to Shaq God bless that woman little
Shacks yeah which they probably weren't
so little no
I wonder what they how big they were at
Birth and I'm sure I think I actually
read somewhere one of his kids I think
is like hoping to be in the NBA so
they're tall they are great right
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is a twofer yes because it's
Bravo news main category subset a Ariana
Maddox tells Tom Sandoval to die in the
first post Affair pump rules trailer so
the inner pump rules released the
mid-season trailer yesterday and it's
what we can expect to see the rest of
the season a lot of stuff that we knew
that was coming
sheena's wedding
Schwartz and Raquel making out they
edited some footage to look to
point us in the direction of like Tom
and Raquel a little bit but there is a
scene at the end where Tom's like going
through the cupboard Sandoval is going
through the cupboard and it's like can I
get you anything or do you uh what does
he say
he said you want anything and Ariana
says for you to die such a good [__]
answer so I think it's that that might
have been filmed post scan of all like
that yeah I think by the way a lot of it
was filmed post-scannibal because when
sheena's sitting in that like white
furry bucket hat those are the paparazzi
pictures of her walking into Ariana's
house like I would they literally threw
together this mid-season finale with the
footage they've shot in the last two
weeks okay great most of it I was hoping
that some of it was from the new footage
I figured that like this stuff from not
you know Ariana saying to die but some
of the other stuff was um from the
actual season because like sheena's
always crying in a bucket house yeah
whatever no but that's that's it okay
now I need to watch it again like
hearing what Sheena said no I've watched
it 45 000 times like looking for new
like facts New Leads new clips and like
tips
um it looks very good I I'm curious if
they're you know gonna continue with the
rest of the season unedited and then add
more or cut out some of the crap we're
gonna probably end up watching this
season I think add more they said that
they're not re-editing the episodes this
is a boom for Vanderpump like now they
have extra episodes that's like more at
what Advertiser wouldn't buy into yeah
any other show that's waiting to get on
the air is going to have to wait like
yeah we don't care uh and it seems like
every episode that's coming out Andy
keeps saying like the foreshadowing is
crazy you know in tonight's episode like
Sheena has a conversation with Raquel
being like calling her a home wrecking
[__] like as a joke about like hooking
up with Schwartz right right she said I
was the original homeworking [__] then
it was LaLa now it's you
so true no you know what
so true and I know given like the the
way we've been talking since the most
recent episode of Enterprise you guys
might think like I'm not team Ariana but
like I totally am no Ariana hasn't
offended me in the last
we were saying yesterday how like you
know the girls who are all speaking on
behalf of Ariana are like going so hard
and being almost thirsty
um when it's really important to
remember that Katie and Ariane are the
only two people on this entire show who
have never cheated on their spouses so
like lala being so mad when she was a
mistress Sheena being so mad when she
was a mistress again she went Lala and
Sheena weren't friends with the girls
but still it's still cheating so the the
moral High Ground everyone has found
themselves on in my opinion is extremely
unfounded and they have no right to be
there
yeah there's that is a part of it
um especially it like everyone's certain
Dynamics are different it's like lala
was you know the m word which she hates
to be called but also she hooked up with
Raquel's boyfriend when Raquel was
dating him like eh you don't get as much
Sheena was a mistress and she defended
Raquel all season and encouraged some of
this nefarious Behavior with friends is
men next you don't get a say
Katie gets to say because she was on the
receiving end of Raquel's nefarious
behavior and because she's never done
this in a situation of course Ariana is
the complete victim here but
everyone's like you know a little bit
like
high and mighty look in the mirror just
a little you know yeah
yeah but also it's like when they did
those things they went through it so
like when you're right it's passage no
and so like yeah Raquel's did it
yesterday like we're talking about it
today right right right and honestly I
am less focused on Raquel like for me
this is all about Tom Sandoval it's
always been about Tom Sandoval I've been
saying since the day I started watching
the show he's literally the worst person
on the face of the planet now everyone
believes me but I feel like everyone's
getting caught up in the Raquel Rachel
drama but it's like let's not [__]
forget about Tom Sandoval I feel like
people are forgetting also like calling
her Rachel like just does nothing for me
no it's like like people are like her
name is not even Raquel she's thirsty
she's a stage name okay so does Lala
sodas Jacks Jax's name was Jason couchy
Lala's name is Lauren like it's not a
good read everyone's being like Rachel
it's not a good reason it's cringe it's
actually just makes it a little
confusing just because there are already
so many characters in this yeah and it's
like wait who's Rachel so true
okay well every night like literally
Zach comes in he's like is vanderprom on
tonight oh that's so cute it's on
tomorrow right tomorrow we're like
obsessed it's so good it's so good and
the thing is even though we haven't
gotten to the meat and potatoes yet like
I'm still living for it so I don't think
they should edit anything I think that
they should it's playing out in a way
that's really letting us see like the
villain origin story the villain origin
story so the trailer that drop was
really good and now I need to go watch
it again knowing that sheena's bucket
hat was last week yes yes those are yeah
and then are you ready for part two of
Bravo news that I found so exciting
summer house star Sierra Miller is
Bravo's first Victoria's Secret model I
love this Sierra is the first Bravo
Liberty to become a Victoria's Secret
model posing in bras panties robes and
athletic wear for a new photo shoot
featured on the lingerie Giants website
she told page six style exclusively it's
been a dream for as long as I can
remember to work for Victoria's Secret
she joined the show as a primarily as a
working ICU nurse but she's been
modeling since she was just 15 she said
I put myself through nursing school
working as a model so it's always been a
positive Venture for me of course
working as a Victoria's Secret model is
the ultimate goal uh she said she's
still thoroughly shocked when she saw
herself splashed across the vs website
the pictures are absolutely gorgeous and
she said she hopes to continue working
with the brand I would love to walk in
the iconic Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show which is set to return this year
after a four-year Hiatus that was going
to be my question
um I'm assuming if they're doing like
this big partnership with her that
it's definitely a possibility I don't
know why it wouldn't be she's Perfection
and I mean if anyone from Bravo was
going to become a Victoria Secret model
it had to be someone from summer house
because they're always in bathing suits
um and so it being Sierra is perfection
I didn't even know she had modeling
experience that's just like a chariot
like her thing is like model sash nurse
I don't remember that I just remember
nurse oh I remember there was a model in
there well I love that and I think this
is great I'm so happy for her yeah if
the show is like a walking fashion show
where they're gonna have
Angels influencers brand ambassadors
walking like I really hope she walks but
I feel like I don't know where I saw
this I think it might have been in our
comments like the someone said the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show like
isn't going to be like a fashion show I
don't know it's like maybe
so it's not a real fashion show that
feels like maybe it's like a
presentation or I don't know I don't
know but I can't remember what I heard
but like something about it threw a
wrench into things for me all right I
mean we'll wait and see but I hope she
walks out I'm glad that she's open to
walking you know because obviously
there's so much negativity surrounding
the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show but
on the one hand like it would be a huge
opportunity for someone
on the other hand they might not want to
be associated with like the stain of it
right right but I think for like you
know a model turned nurse turn reality
star it's a huge opportunity you would
never turn that down and you I don't
think that you should so I hope to see
Sierra up there shaking that thing I'd
rather see you out there shaking that
thing Jax you would hopefully they'll
have a pregnant woman and I would love
to see it I would love to see it but
I'll be okay if they didn't yeah oh you
but you I wouldn't pick it you'll be out
of a job
oh it could be me oh my God literally
never would you ever do it I feel like I
would sooner do it pregnant 100 right
because then nobody could call you fast
literally
um I just want to say like total
tangent like sorry I have no nail polish
left on my nails I was like so anxious
in the thing yesterday I left um I had
like a tissue in my lap and I literally
collected like chips of my nail polish
until there's nothing left and all my
nails are broken like I am disgusting
Claudia that's beautiful I think I'm
gonna get a manicure today if you should
do something like that like a little
self-care for turdy Lou maybe like a
scalp massage I can't like I can't I
have so many things to do I have to take
care of my son I need to text Frank he
doesn't have two working eyes no you
know I'm feeling now at the end of the
show let's do a follow-up from you know
we're from where we started which was
[__] dark I apologize
um I'm feeling better I think I'll make
it to physical therapy okay good you
might relax like that might be like
sometimes you don't need a nap you just
need like to quiet your mind
yeah I think you should meditate
I don't think so I did it once I
remember you told me and it was so
relaxing I did like a 20 minute session
and it was just what I needed like
because I didn't have the time to take a
nap also naps make me feel like crap and
so I meditated and literally my mind
shut down it like it was like a reboot
for the mind I'm just saying
I think that's what you need think about
it yeah like put on there's a million I
had done it with the aura Ring app but
you could do the Calm app
you have to listen to you have to listen
to what they're saying and they will put
you in a trance I just don't know how
people meditate like how do you either
do a guide in meditation let someone let
someone tell you how no I know what I'm
saying like how do you stop yourself
from either falling asleep or like
thinking about like you're anxious you
know intrusive thoughts no you either
focus on what the guide is saying or if
you do fall asleep like great you're
very relaxed it's very meditative to be
asleep yeah like I think towards the end
I like got a couple minutes of shut eye
and like I felt really good because I
didn't go into like a deep Bears nap
right but I was like it was a reboot for
the mind
okay I'll think about it
Turtle added to the list
well aren't you proud of me now I'm
saying I'll think about it not like now
Ed socks that's so true gross it's
called growth Jacks it's called growth
you are a grower not a shower
I am most certainly a grower
um that's our show
you didn't take the people out today
what you want to take them home sure
well I'm gonna take you till five
o'clock because that is when freaking
Fred so if you don't know what that is
and it's like what do you guys keep
saying freaking Fred we are doing a live
show tonight at five o'clock on Via our
patreon Channel awesome via VIA patreon
so if you are a patron like this is not
news to you but if you're not a patron
basically you could sign up right now
patreon.com the toast at 4 55 eastern
time we will drop a link for where you
can watch our live show and we will
start at five o'clock and Claudia and I
are just gonna be like
girlying talking about pop culture we
talk about like the big subjects of the
week and then also there's a live chat
so we get to get your guys's opinions on
stuff which is really exciting and I
feel like this one is going to be really
funny weirdly a few days ago was
watching last month's I don't know why
it just came up um something and it was
thoroughly enjoying it and it's just
really relaxing and fun and it's really
fun it's such a good way to like wind
down for the day it is and it's just
like bonus content from your girly so
patreon accomplish a toast will be live
at 5 PM eastern time until then we hope
you have an amazing day thank you so
much for listening to the toast the
millennial podcast period you can find
us anywhere listen to podcasts and on
YouTube and if you're listening on
YouTube please leave a thumbs up don't
feel free just do it and subscribe and
give us lots of love and engagement we
shall see you tomorrow bye I like that
bye I don't do it exactly like you no
Emma I have my own mind you're an
independent woman girl I have I'm of my
own mind
she's of her own mind don't forget it